what gives me a firework side
try two involved bubble
doe or soda my name is collin and one
of the profiles of
of soda parts of the shocking in other
and so i can play little bit of or oh
oh i do it so it's a nice  chic
and focus on one
project you also have to follow them in and that
swift the ocean cleanup
old made your even plastic qualification
becomes deep learning
tourists lilibet contexts but as our
mission is to enable social relations
it to leverage the power of details and
who  access nou vertu is how you make oil
we working together with love guru
musicians
add shampoo or third sun we fill is
foundation
was om governmental organizations the
cda is you focusing om mondeo is a
handsome we silent melted mill museum stoutste
would it to knit two years ago
access loop en toe and pierce also
about for now if you because apps
build a nice formation on your goal feel
free to check your website through full was
a linkedin from the dm so  it will also be a
bar mount project who is quite
some exciting projects
and who is your bos built-in app for about
the may be interesting to mention
so die part of the jets community and
macho 700 euros fat the city will be
three four years ago
eindhoven and tilburg  university this is
how it
started details campus together
in den bosch budgets how you're the
gradual of the master program de is
now very quiet and completes the jets
playground program which so now a
script to connect to the start-ups and
rice  and in details
what with get u the problems trend s of
you probably know
the situation of plastic needed between
blouse
is quite a serious threat to things
finance ex lead to you man half is
special in land him
ladder plastic is bingo gardens and
fewer especialy  and the mill came
countries people live alongside hits
the plastic just kids disco the winter and
in trimmer
and the flows into the ocean a ladder
fat just dares then middle of the ocean
stee  ds berg
because a lot of people that grader when we
minimal boring is also as get consumed by
nanomol
and pines and om our and him on a trip ever put
your rennet peach wimps 100v ideal
way that is a conventional
business and serious problem
tunnel so the economy problem  is quite
big in sex fact that one night in
billion in a closet in curt i had a
fresh plastic pollution like x factor'
that one percent or the plastic pollution
in the oceans the wife song river and that
like just a focus things around ebay
for the see how fashionable cleanup but the
flight or so new invention the
interceptor
nobody is the pro model sticks so
d-line is there few months ago
how we chester solution to get plastic
car service wat je ferienwohnung picasso
is your gadget car factory as before the
cats  in videos in your percentages ladder
damage
the idea who looking at the slide idea
of ​​problem and that is the qualification
or whether hamas plastic is a rubbers this
ladder of everything the field  ear die in the
passengers
word excel eeckhout
when and where plastics had to rivers
is largely gradually doing as soon as oar die
sam solutions for qualifying plastics en
in rivers
om die won en 2f competition' mals
je beast om
dan or secondary
dh sets sisters how be management  or
though finnen can video had me now
people life long have lost rivers and death
grips en lof insight early and if
you angle shampoo humberstone
is probably the following two and river
in sint in seriously and again
have that is i give you tickles
insight that you  well you don't at half past 1
or 2
action xlii effectively middlegate the
problem when the hand you have it or
manual solutions such as mood under
bridge and coaching again tell-tale
roaring in net a collecting plastics
you will no but can of the breeze in the
reuver
as you might and this is not very stable
show god does is for mechanic and already
so far we defqon she pushed his mouth
orifice and beetle comes out hungry
ch  drivers that consultation bleeds lat so
appreciate that you screen on it
who was following them can use camera
as for distribution and cam here is good
cameras in a locations to monitor
plastics and then or there was a
so caitlin flypo solution for so
qualification
so state the experiment ring
bluff december as they think sam
security camera is what you just took of
yourself and moon to do bridges in
jakarta and collecte
imagerie in advance something like
how is looks a bit like this way of the
image en des lams plastic in  de
we they soon realized that it was quite
difficult to extract file information
if you donut do that manually it's
still not making that much game
so that both he kim in he was the points
looking for teasers and he decided to
write the ocean cleanup picasso
delve into full ring then football and
there it stands for a week
kind of lose so the stop i white
plastic quantification of objects
textile networks the wax the marquises
you become a series leadership
so allow and before i could fusion like
tardis as with voters
the site  already hear that was deposit soda and
long do we know what finish couple of teasers
we decided to continue
collaboration and development of the
solution and ze partnership between zo
danio's button so son of such a beautiful
with presentation this shift from teams to
what's more professional partnership  so
the issue was in the beginning in common
use the learning before the jump
well he was a week said the begining
it is and it to deep learning course
they are your hobbies rule where
editing is possible or that coloring and for
us if it  everthing is possible
a bit more skeptical was who i said
that was quite kon vist that we could do
something but mostly yes it will also be
a lesson stiff we win
how is here what can help orange city we
town thing
yo xlii overwhelmed what effert in that is
happening in so so world you will do your
naughty research
joeri the ladder papers and heavy body there
such a this point kern of every wirdum she
tried to  structure
though a what happens and what we
should solutions extent to which shall
bottoms so may we say we go and teacher
love of the fun home or computer vision
is so you in so classification now
even objects text
a segmentation fault is the fun  things
and some point rolls out
ok he can keep reading about this for
four years broccoli en de stil people
who know more about it
dummy to live away from the city to
month
bbs you so kipstand and this be this is
a look around set of oil  more
expiration of over or under theory that
so many sphere would connection used in a and
create solution
so in never to do that you or not share
we have images after all is because
a computer root to be counted  and
broccoli and few months before that
there we are hacked to be organized by with
microsoft and d
labels evil pray or share not that
much becomes an absolute get started so
that was really useful but then the sole
of decisions to make becomes young
to use and  he the ladder put stories
flysheet soflo object detection epa en
yes and am very happy hours that
child marriages less
it is baby in open source framework
expressive of this flow
mix it quite easy tube konstrukt train
and the boy object action models
yourself had your goal  yourself or scores
in has megaloop decisions but it
is easy is any complete to pdf to my
google adwords or for what then you silent
or the make walks decisions to what can or
can or
albarn if you want to use of what can or
he grams  the first ring the tower of
be it was really valuable
is treffer learning and transferring je
siring the reed a means sweat
after the crabs and take it to your to your
problem and learn van wo  rden so is he
bint had for or with fsc through the wood
and this possibly be valuable to my
problem
by the way on the skeptical do you know
the us trends for learning
we then lean one that i don't drag you
dead raise
a means that trains us santing
simple on picasa sor-ie
in computer vision share the hear that so
sense that the computer can learn
for  method leading trolls
so mini features that that doesn't make the
beer factory
seem simpler for a moment the acting correct edges of
lines for difference between an object
in the background
we can learn that for
something which history this point of the
prop because your ex looking at  and that's
why how i vent and the dat using it
first the pat pat cd cassette then that of
shows as the encoding set show
there fans in and 20 doe or plastics for
the turn gladwell ze des  emergency then add
to look at on the red bull ring so much
fun with it was family and lost so
under the lobith becomes you can use
and then will under duress and usool al of
high efficiency models with you focus in
real-time crossing en om  you only
chatter nice he roc models
who about i decided to that we were not
interested in real his monitoring was
surprising vision to have like a few
in you must so process fsi man i have i there
is
yes you you you how not to  be dead
precise
if you live a monitor rivers so you have
15 minutes was one off and that we those
sites your chose for the mole hi means of
expression leak fixed if you hold him a
little eyeworks is that in the
first in which the works and then
pebbles in a vehicle
this review regional lead shampoos to
network that she just regions of
interest
so regions which might come an object
and insects always the the network lessons
vice how did the objects xlii
er object the class that your marriage in full
zo and youth fixed  a scene en en at this
point or the land zo margin lek at first
that this fate of theory led flash to
study bad and we to decided to action
just get started
my renzo much more and the first
single learns is that you go through a fun
lee us if your problem with do you
jeff correct
2000 object it takes less than to 15
hours to train your network and do you have
what the goals or print out tuning line
of expert my experiment action de
that's not very nose so involved lee
who have that  the knife partnership
together pheifer from microsoft and week
or use for processing in azure so
help me here we need to get for 15 hours
for my models how like a half
older
so ladder efficiency game gone and notice
that first en was training to the tracks
arc plastic is wel is also an ex that
cause i also want to sort of the tag the
region
between these two he catches it who we
do quite well om plastic would become in
the beginning thing with organics was willie
challenging and designed to  eventually
dropped organic royal beach moseley
focus on plastics and you know it me too
and i was just to for ibou seemed plastic
is oil quite for associated shape a
context in shape and yes size and ever
what also and i catholic crazy world if
needed justin  dare and whether to push dna and
occasionally for the pre-selection rotation
because twelve
a proof of concept and wise so
important
well if you know how 0 networks learn
tast computer systems glasses new
networks eh messias computer systems
which you learn to perform  and been at
home discover simple and i haven't
see if i simple
it just won't be able to the bag and
both if you hope so offers the boring to
do so nice labeling get out of the house
i think you show the computer a bucket
that they do what they do
anyway traveled and theology help nijs
a pizza a beer labeling session
outside
20 people attendant and was long funx
sweet
both labeling with yourself and you yes is
very eighties  job but dvr for bunch of
coleridge helping out and it seems so long
of
anyway and a thousand object impression
in a few hours which was very cool and
best libido
show in season zo
martinkev er recommend you ever and
looking into
doing setting is make use of sony vegas
is a very next tool benefits labeling
children die recommended by any question
is what is share set sexy large enough
wel je can of course keep investing in
mode  model a belief and surely lack of
a solid pizza mbs essence wound
place it would be fun for ever at some
point you must smoothen share
me just like show experiment in budget
drivers experiment ariely hurts was
the divisors websites what is the potential
and the so expensive  is als zo
divided my parts set into five chunks
and then he started great white shark
which for just 2000 object en traint en
manon that
en dan ik dat leverage preci  sion
before and percent and after
incremental you that the young or to 1000
m2 large and a thousand by something the
judgment data center the skin
energy that found route for 1000 desley
big john of
or two pound shakes patient everse
decision in the leather steps or to
one key and a thousand the jump is only one
point 5% zo this very interesting
because you see that is over the sun de
the game of adding to 1000 on sex is
heard good and evil or you just has m
thousand object
did you know a site  like that much to
do this very interesting for me because
of you extrapolate that could find that
if you wat double demandé it becomes
only be some percent of 5 xp
its game over the so out decide that
formulas was one or divide by 1 of
course look  into what you can do on the
girl morrell
want bunch of tanks with the opinion that
the want so
percent is the liner d dokumentation
simply the cast is so into this just
makes sense and works
detail notation is set  of
showing your computer the first after all
the value is manipulated here some way
is so its time for the computer
it seems like a new object they have wifi
jf have an object of if the most
makes no sense of the few have is bubble
dennis i am  you our rack and iron
of win select so like that
products computer as a budget wide
but davy show the inbox us on a thief
and grace you baby and white show did set
and white eyeworks is lucas
convolutional networks along plus with use
of convolution how it  best die filters
becomes service certain characteristics of
an image and more images slide the more
features can be extract it and so
multiple system that you give him biscuits
so they become the the game he was
because as it becomes the tendency the
object swift 14 my  percent and
then this part a quotation think you
do sexy 2% so the sky jump
then he if we decided to use the front
optimization function and instead of
success greyly de sandwich  momentum and
that i'm your' family future 7
percent extra
and then we decide our goal in
learning not even sure i
learning rode and danny ven charlie what
the section is called percent own what you
were so sweet my final performance of the
men
can  imagine now we think okay sexy
sexy percent if it minus
well this time minus well that factory
ate a new video roll in which we can
process the sweet almond and then there you
will this you will see you that
so in the video  this country plastic just
admit and the men sex label to the
text
most of the plastic further in this in the
server and that it in fairway i said thing
to recruit noise will your soul it for
sam is also show and the
the confidence of the  mobile or the
object start plastic and you see that sam
on the narrow along already bit less we put
nice dust the big bang would do in terms of
modern still some questions to be
jansen how you looking for scalable
solution
who tests winter testing the soon under
compulsion river
if so love the wool it is the sifco t
just through a test test discover the greenhouse
revels can differ full of you
detail consultation oil so that the van types
or organics become the fun at home or wind
sunlight
the cool art and can be
different men's  sunglasses and grapes
and some don't
so how you have mostly they date of
river bouillon cut sunday the evening for
the fingers so we decided to test om
that developed so the full rings
experiment like earth week train and
test madelon de cm divisors at which  is
the first and then we trained models
wie is de mol trains discover won location
we test the part of location and
then de ex tent de de original marlow
sunday de af to the new location and
see how that influence then
and then keep doing that  until you reach a
mix of maximum
availability of deda
en reasult selection quite interesting
we merged that a line that is the the
the baseline
performance of or the revolution became the
modern education  is you see the efforts
decision and dogs exes explosions that
did the monday
additional deda that who has you the
mobile for additional training
found the new location tracy dat
shri old for his plus x that do quite
well the spice being you sing mobile
trains under the  forever
so fat also to sexy hot percent tucson
we all 50% become you san blas it's
wet by milk
have the desire grievance the section
small ladder read and that's xlii
the location in the middle be without
meat cecil additions
rudy the most this point  found that the
train location with walked between les
cedres very interesting but then you
johan tank ok what do you not push
to get to museum levelen kin and you catch
that here of this in view has just
fifty object
discover new location on which is not
doing very well je or the boost
performance up to over a lot for those
patients game and that is of course not
something to ride rome outside is dat is
not great bij de dag show dat di  e of the
view have plus 50 on yes you can only
make a big jump and reinforce girlfriend
did nice to the
location all kinds of she wants problem go
further on modern las question that you
you might ask is ok that's it out of
shape and  guys and nose nose a lot
matters people uneven your bridge and the
world to monitor ham is plastic the
work we don't get performance that the
solar simpler
luckily the team one they put the kempen
was in jakarta to put those bridges at our
web people counting  gay plastic
muslim so good me make use of that
knowledge input is usually in a
boxplot around the website maybe
detection morrell and education visite
visual counting and around the neighborhood susie
hammers plastic discount the per minute
program leader at per midnight square
mother and that is  kind or in the yard in
so a tray see that medium is quite
simple between the two different day the
collection
lefferts plates interesting is ironic
see it on whisker of  the track
detection possible ozpin higher
when setting the can explain why this
case
so give you path to the under xaxis de the
time
you can see that desk leather that is such a
per a play area so in the gays plesk
is in rep and what  you see is winden
amount of plastic is that it is high
like between fire ford and object per
mille er per minute
your stimulus plastic parts manager bolfo
person to count
then the detection mole and the un
do in quite simply for the fitzek something
14  object love it
the detection mobile xlii detex
way more banded and the pine person box
and who i specs the catholic
this person or just counting to when
the witch can that kingdom 15 meters and it
just become very difficult for person
to count
15 yes in shift  you can
object so who I think the de mal is
also performing the young gentleman because
you're too much account so that was
best the conclusion de of the feasibility
study
who believes that this kind of really good
solution model  sales
sam tanks that you don't have to do before you
can actually use it one of them is the
liner
nice you want to help so is a
meekers to mitigate the plastic blocks
based on such a solution and you can that
you er kan so en them videos  live
web productions of pauling boxes and could
find scores does not fair use or then
you will be echo gate so the divine
links and percent this in the in the
dashboard place so gone do you want this yourself
samsung relation
jef nys map where you can see how  we the
problem is still so much
and every and and the pot about dsi have had
the cross section of the river
hammers plastic in
it
for some time for you get their goals we don't have
to do things like witjes to set up your
entire cloud architecture and  that I also
don't mind that much santing that
people of or and then creamy concealer
until they have them does and it takes
question time to do well so voxan
prophets disturbed imogen somewhere
the passages became
the world if not so computer based  to
a scholarship or someone you is the
vlogs deployed and location
picasso down vf the previous loste you can
compare locations to each other
and that's one thing you don't do
gloomy in the cloud
sons something about the hardware and
into and  eating where so with justin
traveling to mention lesbians
week outsourced is big boob i'll have a
cake and after that have baby rush sam
including bridge and love ff mans we
mistake touching it is more the bell testing
in roswell er in solar power you through their
view
james  the the battery every now and then i
guess heights and sigh whatever your easy chair
computer suffers die and of course
the next the cloud something like that 14 minutes wie
generator' burst of 3 buckets and
then you cloud for processing that's
how the steps become  in the near future
dance to tings of the first is
science how yes who has the pepper
incompetent leon de peer review the
lid well before they catch toe but
also for in your butt bidet season dan
everybody in  the field of plastic
pollution can refer to this and use a
solution to create mills you
outside problem concrete that all them texel
zo
de support of the intercept er so of
course i want to get plastic out of the
river and we can use this solution  to
under cheeks and test gays plastic the
interceptor is caring wood will be your
weekend
mounting camera up stream of
interceptor and want ice cream and then
we can see what they from seth' means
expression greek to us so
floating around in the future collective  clever third
week and related eda
the plastic catch add simply
share and this even helps your product for
of tomorrow the day after tomorrow
hms plastic te intercept there is likely to
catch with you valuable information
picasso van actions that you cant base
om this
en  who what you have the man of you it's
not limited to fix cameras can
unload you that you see in the v bass anyway
experiment in as if we drones
whatever i partner of a red  bridge
for if you looking for some palette so
varies with a very interesting for
research
you pro dine drone mean so pink
prettier softcore like a focus on the
oceans
weekend month kemp was to late chips
crossing the ocean which happening
at home so or wife of time  is every day
and we that we know you map ham is
plastic is where you to write
interception so just some of the
main lessons that aren't hollande do
you know intern cause think family was now
who does lessons
is that 4s push developer  solution nice
so already a wide audience by an expert
together brussels the perfect solution to
us
you not rudy aan de style
can divide the problem through you not a
how much did a what can you models
work well en dan level
eventually implemented and field  and this
blog you so much just another
learning sorry for the neck situation and
just keep improving base and the
and also in this field out think divisors
his sister wants to coat my dat  is that
nobody' is a loon this lot of people
of the same interest with the summer the
people who there follow die then it before
you and you can make use of de nolles
review
if you want to develop a solution like
this would you get out  and real life leather
that this is not a no
off so a month of of doing member types of
study
this is not the no effort under construction boys go
inside a new network the greenhouses can
use framework state building tap full
so knowledge
that determine the field people and that's
really  cool that was like you guys
cool that sure if you are working for a
factory separation project that is
valuable to society
death of te and people communities also
programs that can be every year old
so nutritious try made use of the ef there
is program from for microsoft  and a
pedicure airs from
tons of other programs that can help you
out in foil for the processing power
and maybe someone to if questions to be
afraid to be al so devil i make use of
their
with him a conclusion his address i  s that
the ladder cool stuff kempi dan we share
and that like so
our main vision and soda
ruben age by cola worship and they
did science company how fabric this
domain experts
de week and create and love of value for
them
so like you they can achieve  their
mission in there in a more effective hot
as you mean fine grain definition
crazy so check website of full maturity
linkedin
oh approach more fully the tank you
all for your attention
[Applause]